euh ce matin chapuline de Malerbe la
mère de roman surrizer est revenu sur le
meurtre de Thomas qui secoue la région
et le pays depuis plus d'une semaine
elle a déclaré que le nom des agresseurs
avait été donné bien trop tard selon
elle elle n'est pas la seule à dénoncer
une omerta car les prénoms des
agresseurs seraient devenu un enjeu
politique euh est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec elle est-ce qu'il fallait
donner très vite le nom des agresseurs
euh voilà oui ou
non regardez merci brono ben moi je je
pense que de de ne pas avoir communiqué
sur les prénoms plutôt euh c'était je
trve que c'était indesscent ça je le dis
parce que par respect pour les familles
je ne vois pas pourquoi lorsqu'il s'agit
d'un autre drame et bien on va
communiquer nom prénom tout de suite et
là qui il a été nécessaire
enfin chacun attendait et finalement les
noms circulaient sur les réseaux sociaux
avant qu'il ne soit confirmé par les
autorités
guignole je parlais d' merci Stanislas
Rigo d'être avec nous porte-parole de
reconquête pour vous il fallait donner
les noms bien entendu ou pas ouais bien
sûr et d'ailleurs c'est intéressant que
ce soit la mère de roman stzer qui en
parle ce matin chez votre conur àine de
Malerbe c'est absolument indécent
d'avoir caché aussi longtemps les noms
d'autant que on a appris dans le Figaro
cette semaine que Géral daranin confie
les noms à un ministre et en lui disant
si ça se sait ça peut embraser le pays
ça peut énerver le pays de savoir les
noms mais a pe raison le ministre de
l'intérieur ou la fin enfin ça ça il a
le pou du pays quand même le
ministreintéur c'est très juste mais en
fait il sait que ça va attendre les gens
mais plus il les cache plus il les
dissimule plus les gens demandent plus
les gens demandent et puis quand ça
arrive ça énerve encore plus les gens et
donc je crois que la meilleure des
choses dans ce genre de situation c'est
d'être transparent c'est d'être
transparent sur les profils c'est
transparent sur les noms sur les casies
judiciaires parce que les personnes qui
ont causé le drame de de crpol qui a
conduit à la mort de Thomas ce jeune R
de 16 ans ils sont en plus connus des
services de police donc je crois qu'on a
le droit nous Français de savoir qui
sont les gens qui sèment la terreur dans
notre pays ah oui mais derrière quand le
le ministre de l'Intérieur dit que ça va
il vair un embrasement on peut on peut
aussi le croire il y en a beaucoup ici
qui sont pour qui sont d'accord avec la
mère de morsan suriser notamment Jacques
cardose oui moi je crois que ça sert à
rien de vouloir dissimuler la la vérité
et je suis pour que ce soit le cas quel
que soit le fait divers et de façon à
éviter des interprétations et je trouve
que le fait de le dissimuler fait naître
aussi une forme de peut-être de de
fantasme ou en tous les cas nous amène à
amène une partie du pays à se demander
pourquoi le ministère de l'Intérieur ne
veut pas donner et livrer les les noms
des des des des les prénoms queon
s'appelle Paul ou qu'on s'appelle
Mohamed je pense que quel que soit le le
cas et quel que soit le fait d'ivers
quel que soit ce qui s'est passé à
chaque fois pour moi c'est c'est c'est
la règle devrait être la même et ça
éviterait les fantam oui parce que c'est
contre productif parce que
paradoxalement c'est là où on va encore
plus stigmatiser parce que comme on
imagine et que c'est ça nourrit tous les
fantasmes en disant on nous cache des
choses et cetera bah quand le quand
quand les noms émergent on nous dit bah
Vous vous avez vu on a voulu nous cacher
des choses alors que moi je pense
qu'effectivement la règle doit être la
même pour tous si on on donne pour tout
le monde ou on donne pour personne mais
voilà à partir du moment où on on
commence à donner pour les uns on donne
pour les autres et et et je et je pense
que à l'inverse de ce qui a voulu êt
fait voulu être fait c'est c'estàdire
calmer le pays bah ça a fracturé encore
plus le pays Danny oui ce qui est
scandaleux c'est qu'en plus ils se sont
empressés au début de nous dire que
c'était des Français euh et c'est vrai
mais ensuite ils ont caché les noms
quand ils sont aperçus qu'en fait les
noms n'étaient pas cononance française
donc c'est un véritable mensonge on nous
prend vraiment je suis désolé mais pour
des cons et quand Darmanin a parlé des
Kevin et Matthéo pour les émeutes là les
prénoms cétaent importants il fallait
lesésol je suis entièrement d'accord
avec Daniel Moro c'estàdire ce qui est
intéressant c'est que j'ai eu l'occasion
de débattre notamment sur une autre
chaîne de télévision euh pouro ça
comment tu es sur quelle chaîne je
dirais pas le nom ça va énerver tout le
monde sur le plateau non non c'est une
c'était sur BFM ça va et donc j'étais
sur BFM et quand je dis que parce que ça
ça se murmurait parce que tout le monde
avait vu les images il y a des vidéos
qui ont circulé sur les réseaux sociaux
du début de l'agression et quand on voit
le début les ces vidéos qui traînent et
cetera on comprend le genre de profil
c'est des gens issus de population
immigré maghrébine sauf que ce qui est
scandaleux c'est que quand on le disait
il nous tapait d en dis arrêtez de dire
n'importe quoi c'est pas vrai vous êtes
scandaleux et donc encore une fois il y
a eu une complicité Politi médiatique
pour que les Français ne sachent pas ce
qui s'est réement passé alors g Verz je
reprends Daniel sur un point ahurissant
qui passé comme ça elle a dit on s'est
aperçu que c'était pas des noms à
consonance française ça veut dire que
Gilles c'est français et Souleiman c'est
pas consonance française mais c'est
incroyable de dire ça c'est de la folie
de dire ça on peut pas
Laer
mal RA raison suis désolé des bons noms
français
plus ni l'origine de certain
prisig vu
dire moi je suis totalement contre le
fait qu'on donne ses prénoms d'abord la
justice très souvent pas il y a pas de
règles il y a pas de loi le procureur
fait ce qu'il veut souvent en France on
ne les donne pas et il faut pas être
dupe si on les donne aujourd'hui
pourquoi c'est pour que des monsieurs
des gens comme vous monsieur Rigot
puissiez récupérer politiquement parce
qu'on va être très clair Cyril ah c'est
rachide tiens ça sonne arabe tiens
peut-être qu'il est musulman venu de
l'immigration et Bou on désingle
l'immigration et c'est de la faute de
l'immigration le drame incroyable de la
mort de Thomas bouleversant vous allez
dire maintenant c'est de la faute des
immigrés et ça ça c'est de la
récupération politique h je cro je crois
que justement le vrai sujet là-dessus
c'est pas la récupération ça c'est un
argument bidon parce fa en prétextant
que ce que nous fais ce que nous faisons
c'est de la récupération on occulte le
débat de fond le débat de fond c'est
dans ce pays oui il y a un lien entre
l'insécurité et l'immigration ça c'est
factuel c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
Monsieur Darmanin qui lui-même cachait
les noms je vous donne quelques chiffres
en vraque mais qui vont vous parler et
qui sont pas de moi qui sont de Monsieur
Darmanin 55 % de la délinquence à
Marseille sont le fait de personnes
étrangères 55 % ça veut dire quoi
étrangère ah benah de personnes qui sont
pas de papier ce sont des étrangers dans
les transports en commun c'est 90 % des
vols commis par les étrangers là c'est
des Français oui mais sauf que il y a un
lien entre immigration et délincance
premier élément deuxième élément pas
inintéressant non plus on sait très bien
que ces vagues d'immigration peuvent
causer ce genre de dégâts ça peut être
des dégâtsimmigration oui à 500000 entr
parents vous appelez ça comment vous ah
c'est la submersion migratoire ououi
bien sûr quand il y en a 500000 parents
oui c'est une submersion oui je sais pas
attention quand même au raccourci entre
l'immigration et une automaticité avec
je suis pas certain
du et dit les choses comme ça je pense
pas que vous PZ faire le lien dans tous
les cas le lien il est pas établi comme
ça c'est pas un discours que vous pouvez
reprendre comme ça tranquillement sur un
plateau de télév c'est plus complex
monsieur Dar il fait deux choses il
parle d'ensuvagement terme que je
reprends volontiers et il donne ses
chiffres sans faire un lien avec
l'immigration sauvagement dans la
société ça on est tous d'accord avec
Monsieur de fait de fait fait le lien
puisquil donne ces chiffres là encore
une fois c'est factuel c'est que tous
les immigrés ne sont pas délinquants
mais une grande part de la délinquence
en France criminalité est le fruit de
personnes étrangères tout comme dans nos
prisons il y a 25 % de personnes
étrangèr simpliours c'est pas
automatique mais en tout cas c'est
effuel comme comm les antibiotiques
ouais on vit quand même dans un monde un
peu particulier quand même parce que on
veut maintenant on veut dénoncer
les ces gens pitoyables qui ont qui ont
commis une horreur absolue que tout le
monde bien évidemment
condamne dans le monde dans lequel on
vit aussi actuellement avec Internet ben
finidalement visiblement on n pas besoin
de dénoncer parce que ils se font
dénoncer on connait la photo on connait
l'adresse on connait et ce qui amène à
dénoncer bah ça va aller voir les
parents ça va avoir des meurtres et
encore des bagarres ça va aller faire
des des rencontres qu'il a eu lorsquil y
a eu là avec la descente de l'extrême
droite bon je vous dis moi
personnellement aujourd'hui je suis
assez perdu vraiment parce que on parle
desmigration on parle de dire bah lui il
est n en France ben non parce qu'il
s'appelle Rachid ou il s'appelle mundir
bah il est pas français franchement ça
ça me fait vraiment chier je vous le dis
vraiment ça me fait vraiment chier c'est
très c'est très grave ce qui s'est passé
moi je je sais pas quoi vous dire en
fait pour toi il fallait donner les noms
ou pas non faut pas donner nom parce
qu'il y a une justice et puis quoi qu'il
arrive les noms allent sortir donc quoi
qu'il arrive pourquoi donner les noms
donc donne les noms l'adresse
l'âgef tu crois pas que c'est le
contraire en fait Monir tu crois pas que
le fait que le gouvernement ou le
ministère de l'Intérieur enfin je sais
pas exactement comment les choses se
sont faites ou le procureur de la
République d'ailleurs peut-être le fait
que on ne divulgue pas les noms fait que
dans les jours qui ont suivi c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé ce weekend
finalement bah comme ça a été expliqué
ça circulait sous le manteau et puis il
y a eu cette idée selon laquelle ah le
gouvernement veut cacher parce que
majoritairement sont des nom à
consonance maghrébine et donc du coup ça
fait naître quelque chose à mon avis qui
qui qui vient crisper encore un peu plus
le débat tu vois ce que je veux dire et
donc je me dis moi mais pourquoi ne pas
donner ces informations là de façon très
automatique dès le départ pour éviter
que depuis quand en France on dénonce
enfin on dit nom mais on doit dire les
noms aujourd'hui moi c'est la première
fois j'ai 50 bal c'est la première fois
que pas dénoncer justement c'est de dire
le nom donc le nom prénom et de dire que
le mec est un arabe magrbine c'est le
contraire banalisé il faut dire les
choses met no alors on va se retrouver
dans un instant avec Stan qui Stan Rigo
qui reste avec nous on va revenir sur
Patrick Cohen ce qu'il a dit hier
Patrick Cohen c'est vrai que ça a été un
déferlement aujourd'hui concernant et
puis reste avec nous avec ce témoignage
qui est complètement fou vous allez voir
cette histoire je vous dis avec les
équipes c'est une des histoires les plus
forteson dans T PMP ce sera dans un
instant en direct bien entendu à tout de
suite